well yeah I mean at first it was sort of
panic stations but I've seen there's
hundreds of stuff on the scene straight
away obviously the coulomb everyone was
out the whole area where the spine
actually is that was a virtue eight
straight away and then we've been
probably 10 minutes the whole area is
closed off and they literally probably
eighty to a hundred staff will see back
in people away but it seemed that first
of the big team I suppose those panic
stations but within you know a few
minutes they seem to know whatever did
yeah all the times have released a
statement saying that they had people on
the air on the scene straightaway and
did you see the carriages you left the
queue did you see what was going on well
we can see that we can see the gist of
what happened we can obviously hear
quite a lot screaming from people but we
didn't know why it happened or what
exactly caused the accident we're
hearing that a 999 call was made by
Alton Towers staff to West Midlands
Ambulance how long did it take them to
get to the scene we understand that
there was an air ambulance for
ambulances as well yeah well we've just
got to a local councillor and on the way
we passed four police that four police
cars to a message on the scene but the
evidence was there we could hear the
ambulance we've been five minutes and it
was landed and they seem to got there
pretty quick